[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
fast food restaurants are known for
generally speaking being opposed to
increases to the minimum wage high
percentage of fast-food employees earn
the minimum wage in many states and as a
result are sort of more impacted on a
percentage basis by increases to the
minimum wage than businesses in which
nobody is earning the minimum wage for
example and notably mcdonald's has told
the National Restaurant Association that
they are no longer going to participate
in lobbying at the local state and
federal level against increases to the
minimum wage Jenna Kent who's the vice
president of government relations said
that the company believes wage increases
should be phased in and that all
increases should be treated the same way
this is something that could potentially
open the door to more easygoing
increases to the minimum wage that
Democrats in the House mostly in the
house but also some in the Senate have
been talking about and you know we don't
it's important not to concede more power
than is real to a company like
McDonald's but I think it's just as
important to recognize the importance of
a giant like McDonald's saying that they
are no longer going to participate in
these lobbying efforts now there's two
ways to understand this Pat
the first one is McDonald's has
calculated that the negative PR around
lobbying against minimum wage increases
may cost them more then the minimum wage
increases themselves so that it's sort
of like a business decision and they're
gonna say we're just going to let it go
we think the net effect will be
relatively small the other possibility
is that they're going to continue using
their dollars to indirectly lobby
against minimum wage increases but in
other ways not directly not vocally
maybe not through the National
Restaurant Association but there are
still other ways in which McDonald's can
work
to limit the extent to which the minimum
wage is increased maybe that's just the
kind of cynical me reacting to the the
statement from McDonald's my instinct is
that this is a PR calculation I think
McDonald's recognizes that there has
been a tipping point when it comes to
the minimum wage vast majority of
Americans are in support of raising the
minimum wage and I think if they don't
do it then they stand to be shamed into
it maybe Bernie Sanders Roe kana other
progressives in the Congress will do
something similar to what they did with
the Stop Beezus Act which shames Amazon
into raising the minimum wage at that
company to $15
I just don't think McDonald's wants that
to happen to them - there's another
approach to this which is that the
federal minimum wage right now is 7 2013
the house is to raise it to $15 an hour
by 2024 that's four and a half years
from now there are many economic
analysts who believe it is
extraordinarily unlikely that in the
next four and a half years the minimum
wage is going to more than double and
that would be an approach for McDonald's
saying this isn't going to happen either
way there's so much other opposition to
increases to the minimum wage that we
should just get out of this for whatever
negative impact it could have and will
have we can have our cake and eat it too
and that we can stop getting the
negative attention for opposition to
increases to the minimum wage and it's
not going to happen anyway and that may
be actually the most sort of realpolitik
interpretation which is it's not going
to happen with or without McDonald's is
opposition yeah that's probably true but
maybe a slight increase like the fact
that the federal minimum wage is 725
right now is totally embarrassing it
should at least go up to $10 I think
that's perhaps reasonable even in this
day and age with a republican-controlled
Senate yeah I I think you're probably
right and I am increasingly I don't know
how many times a year
725 is such a low minimum wage that I
something is happening in my brain where
like I can't keep it in there and I
regularly forget that the minimum wage
is still 725 an hour federally here in
Massachusetts it's already 12 dollars an
hour and when you consider that going to
15 is significantly less
then at the federal level going from 725
to 15 but I very often forget that the
federal minimum wage is only 725 an hour
and I get that if you compare $12 an
hour in New York City versus 725 an hour
in you know the middle of nowhere South
Dakota the 725 in the middle of nowhere
South Dakota probably buys you a better
standard of living than 12 bucks an hour
in New York although now I'm remembering
what is the New York City minimum wage
let me look that up oh it's 11:50 it's
even lower yeah so so there's no
question that in some places 725 gets
you a better standard of living than a
higher minimum wage maybe in
Massachusetts or wherever but there's
almost like reverse sticker shock for me
Pat where I see that 725 and I'm like is
that something just look is very wrong
about that number it certainly does and
I think regardless of where you live in
the United States
725 is too low like I can understand
yeah maybe if you live in Kentucky $12
an hour as the minimum wage could be
acceptable whereas New York City you
probably have to do 15 to 18 dollars but
yeah imagine like working a full day
let's say 12 hours and then you don't
even make a hundred dollars for the day
before taxes like that's just not
acceptable yeah and I would even say in
places like New York City I don't even
know that 15 to 18 is a living wage I
think the minimum wage question is a
different one but it's certainly not a
living wage if that's our expectation
so anyway McDonald's will at least not
openly be an impediment to increases to
the minimum wage going forward and we'll
see what if anything that means for the
actual increase to the federal minimum
wage the European Parliament has voted
to stop moving clocks forward an hour in
the spring and back an hour in the fall
this passed by a vote of 410 to 192
these time changes were introduced
during World War one in Europe to save
energy and they are ending them in 2021
the final law hasn't been produced yet
but they are going to have a
conversation with member nations and the
UK has indicated it will stick to the
current system after brexit I don't even
want
oh we talking about brexit on the
Regular Show already I don't want to
open up the brexit can of worms again of
what I do want to bring up I think by
the way first of all I'm for this I
would like the United States also to
stop shifting time zones I don't know
are you on the same page as that yes
permanent daylight savings time that's
what I want yeah and I always get
confused is it permanent daylight saving
time or permanent standard time I don't
know you want perm I have a late I want
a later sunset in the winter that's all
exactly okay that's my concern there's
some really interesting things about
time zones in Europe
and so my stepmom is from northwestern
Spain it's a part of Spain that's
directly above Portugal now Portugal and
Spain are on different time zones Spain
is in the same time zone as Italy and
points significantly east of Spain
whereas Portugal is on the same time
zone as the United Kingdom I think I
have that correct and it really doesn't
make too much sense that if you leave
from northwestern Spain and drive south
you're not moving
east-west at all but you go into
Portugal and it's an hour earlier and it
has a political history which is I again
I'm going from memory here Spain wanted
to be under the times of Franco I
believe wanted to be for business
purposes in the same time zone as Italy
and as a result Spain chose to be part
of that primary sort of Central Europe
time zone rather than the same time zone
as the UK and Ireland and Portugal and
it leads to this very weird thing where
in northwestern Spain in the summer the
Sun often is not even totally set by
10:00 p.m. now that's totally normal if
you are very far north
like you know in Norway or whatever
where they are used to as you get closer
to the Arctic Circle you get those very
very late sunsets or no sunsets at all
during the summer but Spain is not so
far north that that should be going on
but it is because of this political time
zone thing and always found that sort of
interesting a very political
time zone thing which really shouldn't
be I don't know if you feel strongly
about it Pat but I am very very strongly
in favor of Spain getting on the same
time zone as Portugal in the UK yeah
that definitely would make sense I think
there are three states that don't move
the clocks and those are if my memory
serves me correctly Hawaii Indiana and
Arizona now of course
Hawaii is out in the middle of nowhere
so it doesn't matter like if you're
traveling from another state to Hawaii
that you have to change the clocks
because you kind of expect that well
like if you're going from New Mexico to
Arizona you wouldn't think that you'd
have to change the clocks you're going
from Illinois to Indiana you wouldn't
think that you'd have to change the
clocks but of course in both
circumstances you do and that's kind of
like the same thing that they have going
on Spain and Portugal I will say about
this though how awesome is it that the
European Parliament looks like they're
well on their way to passing it here in
the United States we're gonna have to
have a conversation about it for years
to even make it a possibility it doesn't
seem like it's a possibility right now
it's not a voting issue it's not like
it's incredibly important to most people
last month Marco Rubio put out a bill
that I think is called the sunlight
Protection Act and that would make
daylight savings time permanent it's
still just in the introductory phases I
don't think anything will come of it
there's a predictor sight I looked at
that said that it has only a 7% chance
of actually passing so yeah dismal
chances that's what we get here in the
United States I saw an interesting
proposal which would simple it would
eliminate the time change and it would
reduce the u.s. to two time zones so you
would basically have like East and West
you would combine eastern and central
time zone and then you would combine
mountain and Pacific time zone and there
are some wacky repercussions in terms of
what would be happening on the farthest
west and eastern borders of those larger
time zones but it actually wouldn't be
there would be complexities some
complexities with it but it would really
simplify a lot of things and they might
not be one separated by so there's two
ideas one is that they are separated by
one hour so when in the East it's 1:00
p.m. in the West it's 12:00 p.m. but
there's a different proposal I saw which
would simplify to two main US time zone
but they would be separated by two hours
which would be kind of weird because you
could cross a state border from one to
the next and it's not one hour earlier
but two hours earlier which I guess
could have its own kind of video sync
receives but honestly I'm open to any of
these proposals if someone can make a
good case for it being a change in the
positive direction yeah and you would be
able to time travel like if you did
something in the past hour or two that
you regretted you could just change time
zones and then you'd have the
opportunity to undo it yeah well to the
extent that you can do that you can do
that already it's just only by one hour
rather than two I guess the thing it
can't take more than an hour if you want
to do it but not where my mind goes I
have to say when I think about time
zones a Florida man died this weekend
while reportedly trying to remove one of
his pet pigeons from a powerline using a
20 foot aluminum pool Pole which of
course is made out of metal and it's a
really bad idea the 36 year old elyon
garcia Rivera was electrocuted in West
Palm Beach and found unresponsive near
his pigeon coop on his property there
apparently was a pigeon that was just
hanging out on this powerline and he
tried to grab it with this long 20 foot
pole and was tragically electrocuted
when the pole touched the power line he
was taken to a local hospital and
pronounced dead of course this is a bad
idea
you never want to do anything like this
with power lines you never know what's
live you particularly don't want to use
metal but I I don't know how much we
have to add about the electrocution pad
I want to talk about the pigeon coop
thing this is a I've always been
fascinated by people who are interested
in keeping pigeons as a hobby I know
Mike Tyson did it there are stories in
the book Donnie Brasco about undercover
FBI agent Joe Pistone who went
undercover with the New York in the New
York Mafia families crime families as
Donnie Brasco about some of the big or
mid-level
mobsters having pigeon coops on the
terraces of their buildings in Brooklyn
it's just always struck me as an unusual
and fascinating hobby
yeah Nikola Tesla - he was of course
famous inventor scientist
and at the end of his life I think he
was maybe suffering from some sort of
dementia or some sort of cognitive
decline he started keeping pigeons and
there was one pigeon that he liked in
particular he said that he loved that
pigeon like one would love a woman and
that's a little bit concerning that
maybe going a little bit too far I think
that might be just a step too far in the
pigeon pigeon husbandry or I guess it's
not really husbandry you're not really
mating the pigeons but maybe maybe they
made her own I don't really know that
much about pigeons but in any case their
ability to return to particular
locations and find their ways is pretty
interesting and anything Mike Tyson was
into has to be interesting or wacky in
some way shape or form but once again I
don't think I have to tell most of our
audience assume every power line is live
never go near them with metal and I
don't know what other what other advice
we can glean from this story yeah to be
fair this man probably didn't have a 20
foot wooden pole so in that sense it's
it's sort of excusable also side note
here I didn't learn until a few years
ago that doves and pigeons are
essentially the same thing like I think
they're the same species of bird except
doves are white that blew my mind when I
found that out because doves are thought
of as so beautiful and peaceful and
innocent and pigeons are those annoying
City creatures that you just want to
shoo away so what I'm seeing is that
both doves and pigeons are part of the
three-part are of the same wait a second
both dove and pigeon refer to the 308
species of birds from the columbidae
family there's no difference between a
pigeon and a dove in scientific
nomenclature but colloquially English
tends to categorize them by size doves
tend to be smaller than what we call
pigeons although this is not always the
case and that yeah I guess you're
there's no difference between a dove and
a pigeon and they don't even mention the
color I mean maybe that's the sort of
colloquial understanding if you see a
white one you call it a dove but it
appears that they're the same thing and
never would have occurred to me yeah
exactly I think we're breaking
News - a lot of people here I thought
that you know because I just found this
out a few years ago maybe other people
didn't know as well but that's often not
the case for other things usually it's
just me who's left in the dark yeah this
is uh this is like when Trump says you
know a lot of people don't know X and
it's like no no most people do know that
it's just you learned it five minutes
ago before you got in front of a
microphone we have to be uh got to be
careful about using trumpism that does
it for today new show new bonus show
tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]